(crunches)
(screams)
♪ Brickleberry
- Oh boy, oh boy, oh
boy, that means I get
to sleep in the bed with
Ethel, like we always do,
'cause we're married
and we've explored
every wet, dark crevice
of each others bodies.
(screams)
- Woody, could I?
- No, (bleep) off.
♪ He stuck a feather in his hat
♪ And called it macaroni
Can I get a glass of tap water?
- Beat it, Sea World.
(whacks)
- Not that I'm aware of.
(screams)
- It's weird, Dad, I
can't feel my face.
I think we're dead.
I've got bugs all over me.
(groans)
Oh no, my lesbian
strength, it's gone.
Oh my heavens, I broke a nail.
(gasps)
(groans)
(whacks)
(cheers)
So, what are you
doing after the game?
- I think you have the
wrong impression of me.
I'm a lesbian, sir.
- Ouch.
- I'll be back for that
big flappy-dappy ass.
(blubbering)
♪ brickleberry